[Musique]
quatre chemins c'est une promesse que
j'ai faite avec l'émission radiophonique
par quatre chemins qui l'animé pendant
43 ans jacques languirand a marqué
l'imaginaire collectif pour moi comme
pour beaucoup d'autres je pense que
jacques languirand c'est quelqu'un qui
nous a amené ailleurs il était à la fois
très sage est à la fois il se prenait
pas trop sérieuses avec sourire et ses
réflexions qu'il qualifiait de tribe
hâtives
celui que plusieurs appelait tout
simplement languirand abordait les idées
avec agilité et élégance languirand il a
passé sa vie je pense à chercher à
s'instruire
il a profité de tous les grands courants
de pensée pour pénétrer chez courant là
essayer de les comprendre
toujours vécu à la jeunesse dans un
milieu familial dans le mois que je
puisse dire est qu il était assez
instable mais à montréal en 1931
jacques languirand a été un des acteurs
de la révolution tranquille des années
60 d'abord au théâtre puis en se
retrouvant dans des émissions de
télévision
vous allez voir n'est ce pas un petit
point lumineux se déplacer sur votre
écran de télévision
jacques languirand c'est une bête de
somme ça a été une bête de somme
quelqu'un qui a travaillé énormément
puis avec une capacité de travail
considérable aujourd'hui lundi 13
septembre 1971 directement du studio 24
de radio canada montréal
c'est en 1971 qu'il anime pour la
première fois à l'émission par quatre
chemins
parallèlement il a tout au long de sa
carrière publié plusieurs romans des
essais et des ouvrages de vulgarisation
dont plusieurs ont été acclamés par la
critique à des deux lecteurs sa
bibliothèque comptait plus de dix mille
ouvrages ce passeur de culture a reçu de
multiples honneurs et décoration tout au
long de sa carrière
[Applaudissements]
une autre affaire
c'est en 2014 qu'il quitte la barre de
son émission par 4 chemins
atteint par la maladie d'alzheimer sa
réputation a été ternie en 2016 par des
allégations d'inceste envers sa fille
des allégations qui n'ont jamais été
prouvées l'héritage culturel qui laisse
derrière lui demeurent importants
jacques languirand était un libre
penseur sans cesse ouvert aux nouvelles
idées
certains diront qu'il est un pionnier
animé d'un brin de folie car les gens
vont voir sur dans les archives oubliées
de cha siffler
ils vont s'appeler 10 le dos des biens
mois reçoit chose nous dit que le savez
ici oui je déprimais radio canada
montréal